lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
hallar la medida del ángulo de eje muy
bien entonces me estoy refiriendo a este
ángulo el ángulo de eje y te invito a
que hagas una pausa y trates de resolver
este problema por tu propia cuenta
muy bien ahora vamos a hacerlo todos
juntos y la clave aquí es ver que este
ángulo que hemos marcado en realidad
también es un ángulo inscrito ya que el
vértice está localizado en la
circunferencia muy bien entonces lo que
hay que hacer es pensar en el arco que
sostiene verdad y entonces para que sea
todo más claro voy a dibujar esto voy a
resaltar estos lados más bien vamos a
resaltar estos lados muy bien tenemos
aquí el segmento d
y el segmento c
y justamente podemos ver que ese ángulo
sostiene al arco cede muy bien aquí está
el ángulo sosteniendo al arco se ve muy
bien entonces de esto podemos concluir
que la medida del ángulo inscrito es
igual a la mitad de la medida del arco
sé de verdad entonces lo único que
tenemos que hacer es calcular la medida
del arco cede
si podemos calcular la medida de este
arco simplemente habrá que dividirlo
entre dos y obtendremos la medida del
ángulo muy bien ok entonces todo esto lo
podemos hacer porque también hay otro
ángulo inscrito que sostiene al arco
sede y que es el que voy a dibujar o voy
a remarcar en unos momentos verdad
tenemos por ejemplo el ángulo c
fd tenemos el ángulo
muy bien este ángulo también sostiene al
arco cede así que en realidad tenemos
dos formas de pensar este problema la
primera forma digamos es que dos ángulos
inscritos que sostienen el mismo arco
entonces tendrán la misma medida así que
a partir de esto podemos concluir que el
ángulo de eje
tiene tiene una medida de 50 grados
verdad ambos deben medir 50 grados
porque estoy a media 50 grados o también
puedes calcular la medida del arco sé de
verdad esto en realidad sería el doble
del ángulo inscrito que lo sostiene y en
este caso el ángulo inscrito que lo
sostiene es de 50 grados por lo tanto
esto me diría
grados verdad y luego el ángulo inscrito
es la mitad de la medida del arco de
verdad entonces este ángulo inscrito
tiene la mitad de esta medida que en
este caso serían 50 grados bueno no
importa de qué forma lo hayan resuelto
en cualquier caso se obtienen 50 grados